if you spent the start of your week
pacing around the house and not playing
destiny because of Sony's PSN service
being knocked offline again you might be
glad to hear that Sony intends to
compensate for your lost time I'm Kate
and this is your GameSpot news update
Sony has promised to extend PS Plus and
PS now subscriptions for existing users
following the PSN outage that not Sony's
game network offline on Monday writing
on the official PlayStation Twitter page
Sony thanked users for their patience
while the company worked to restore the
network it added the players should stay
tuned for details on PS + PS now and
video rental extensions it isn't
currently clear how long Sony will
extend user subscriptions for as a means
to reimburse for the downtime which
lasted about 10 hours a hacker group
which calls itself phantom squad has
claimed responsibility for knocking the
PSN services offline what did you do
instead of playing games while PSN was
down do you think Sony's apology makes
up for it are you tired of hackers let
us know in the comments or come and find
me on Twitter I'm at how not to draw
remember to keep it gamespot.com for
your update and thanks for watching